as president I think my my
responsibility is to the notion of all
people created equal I as president
quite the opposite of what you just said
as president hey I want the whole notion
of of my presidency would be please be
who you want to be do what you want to
do spread your wings and soar if you get
to the point where you're infringing on
the rights of other people you're going
to have a hard time how would you feel
if a uh if a man decided to a male
politician decided to suddenly identify
as female and became the first woman
president of the United States I'd be
like damn
I mean I think it would be illegal or
that it's I didn't say it'd be illegal
that's the whole point the whole point
uh Madame would be president it's
perfectly legal I think well that's mine
it's just wrong I don't even think it's
wrong it's just we I think we're all uh
down a few glasses of wine that night we
wouldn't be real happy about it